sólo por el caso de que nos encontremos
un nombre o un gnomo que nos pregunte
cuánto dinero y qué tipo de dinero tiene
en su cartera mejor vamos a repasar un
poco estos sistemas de ecuaciones por si
llega ese día y bueno en este caso tengo
este par de ecuaciones tengo este
sistema de ecuaciones que dice gráfica y
resuelve el sistema de ecuaciones y
bueno si te das cuenta aquí tengo un
plano cartesiano y tengo dos rectas así
que vamos a graficar este par de
ecuaciones y además vamos a poner en qué
punto se intersectan ambas rectas justo
aquí y bueno para esto quiero que te des
cuenta que la primera dice james es
igual a menos dos tercios de x más 1 y
de una forma muy sencilla podemos ver en
qué punto intersecta al eje del ay es
esta recta está en su forma pendiente
ordenada al origen y por lo tanto
podemos decir que en el valor de 1
interceptamos el eje de las 10 así que
déjame ponerlo por aquí me voy a mover
al valor de 1 y justo aquí es donde
interceptamos a elegir las yes ahora
para encontrar el otro punto que
necesitamos para saber la gráfica de
ésta
de esta ecuación de azul que tengo aquí
me voy a fijar en la pendiente y la
pendiente me dice menos dos tercios es
decir que por cada tres que camine yo en
x voy a bajar dos en yen y justo
utilizando la pendiente vamos a poner el
otro punto dado este punto que acabo de
acomodar aquí voy a caminar tres hacia
la derecha 3 en x 123 y voy a bajar 12 y
12 justo aquí justo aquí está el otro
punto y ahora sí puedo asegurar que la
gráfica de la recta y es igual a menos
dos tercios de x + 1 es esta de azul
ahora vamos a hacer exactamente lo mismo
con la gráfica de verde tengo que esta
recta también está dada en su forma
pendiente ordenar el origen y por lo
tanto sabemos que cortamos al eje de las
10 en el valor de 5 así que déjenme
poner uno de los puntos aquí en el valor
de 5 en el eje de las 10 y después me
voy a fijar de igual manera en su
pendiente tengo una pendiente de dos
tercios lo que quiere decir que por cada
tres que camine en x voy a subir en esta
ocasión voy a subir porque tengo una
pendiente
voy a subir 2 así que hagámoslo voy a
ponerme en este punto en este punto que
sabemos que está en mi recta y voy a
caminar 3 hacia la derecha 1 2 3 y ahora
voy a subir 2 en 1
2 de lujo ya tengo también la
representación gráfica de esta ecuación
de verde la función y igual a dos
tercios de x + 5 tiene como gráfica esta
de aquí y si te das cuenta ya podemos
ver en qué punto se intersectan ambas
rectas ambas rectas se interceptan en
este punto de aquí cuando x vale menos
12 menos 3 cuando x vale menos 3 que
valen 1 2 3 3 es decir que cuando x vale
menos 3 lo voy a poner justo aquí y ya
vale 3 positivo 3 positivo estamos en el
punto donde se intersectan ambas rectas
y por lo tanto podemos decir que son los
valores que solucionan este sistema de
ecuaciones ahora si comprobamos la
respuesta y de lujo estamos bien buena
manera de practicar un sistema de
ecuaciones de una manera visual